Với mục biểu đưa vào khai thác bà nhìn kêu lo mét đường cao tốc và cuối năm 2020, việc nâng cao chất lượng công tắc quản lý, vất hành và bảo chí đường cao tốc,
càng chở nên cấp thiết hình bao giờ hết. Theo số lượng thống kê đến hết thống bẩy năm 2020, cả nước có gần 20% kêu lo mét đường cao tốc.
Trong đó, cao tốc bất năm phía đồng đã đưa vào khai thác sự dụng hơn 1,2% kêu lo mét, con lại là các tưởng cao tốc nhắn cao tốc,
nối liền Trung tâm hành chính lớn giữa các vùng miền liền vùng kinh tế. Theo một kêu đưa ra, đến hết năm 2020,
sẽ hoàn thành và đưa vào sự dụng khoảng 30% mấy mấy cái lo mét nữa để đặt một tiêu cả nước,
có bao nhiêu cái lo mét và cuối năm này. Dù vậy, trong công tắc quản lý, vận hành đến nay vẫn còn nhiều bất cập,
thậm chí một số tiêu trình quy trình còn chưa bàn hành. Thêm vào đó, sự thiếu nhất quán,
thiếu thực tế trong áp dụng tiêu trình kỹ thuật về tốc độ, vị trí biển bảo, tất nhiệp lần xe,
đã kê ra sự mối giối lúng túng cho lại xe khi dị truyền. Một số tiến cao tốc còn thiếu trạm dừng nghi, trạm cấp nhìn liệu,
cơ chế quan lý thu vi cũng còn nhiều bất cập. Phần công chức nghiệm giữa các quan quá li nhà nước,
chủ đồ từ vấn đơn vị vấn hành khai thác, loy khi còn trồng chéo thiếu gió rằng,
đây là người dân giấn đến khó khăn trong sự li sự gố, giải quyết khíu này hoặc trên khai sự chữa khẩn cấp.